are we back online
yet we are back
online you may thank Xfinity for the
outage please let them know that they
are Dumbo
sucks
okay well in the meantime I got a couple
little things done on the file reading
so what we should be able to
do is instead of malaking the map
right game
map.
numpy
okay and then where's the AI paths
yeah this one here
right
press and we already have the offset so
this is literally all we have to
do and then we just have to do
three M map three AI paths all
right no there's a little bit more than
that right because it's this map
structure here which is grid so it's
actually
hold on we messed something up
here so it's n map does need to get
Malik n map grid needs to get allocated
this
way free so you have to free and AI
paths
free map grid fre map re Okay so here is
our memory
management accounted
for this now uh
right there's still some data that
you're not accounting for
yet okay so first of all we're going to
call this with the right ARS right
we don't want to copy do we want to copy
the grid
wait we want to test this from native C
actually is what we want to do so what
we should do is
MOA
H so what we're going to do is we're
going to put this down
here we're going to do void
main the void main or you usually do int
for return code I don't
know
do num agents num neutrals
okay num agents equals
neutrals we don't really need all of
these
allocated this MOA and get rid of all
this
garbage goal here is to get this running
in purec as a test now we don't have the
renderer ported yet so we'll still have
to do that but this is well on its way
right return type
int that's what I thought in in okay so
now this actually runs was curious I
just started the YouTube video yeah you
can thank Xfinity for that
shake I do like
um one to two cups of of chocolate milk
two or three cups of whole milk and
um not a normal scoop I use like a half
cup measuring scoop of whey
isolate unflavored whey isolate
I motivating me to get back to the
gym I like the lifting the running
drives me nuts I do the running anyways
I've done two marathons and the 50k this
year
those were the only three
um the running is relatively new I
didn't start running seriously until
about a year ago and then the lifting
has been about four years now
um I'm right now I'm I'm at my alltime
best upper body lifts but my lower body
lifts are quite bad because of all the
running though I'm starting to get back
into those
now yeah the running is a pain the
running is a real pain I do it anyways
but
at the very least I'm no longer letting
my running um just prevent me from doing
anything else no I don't listen to music
while I run I get way too bored with
just music I listen to audio
music what audio books random fantasy
stuff man for the most part sometimes
sci-fi let's see I went through the
whole Lord of the Ring Series this year
pretty much the whole culture Series in
Banks and then the whole Aragon series
all last book of that at the
moment I don't
know the next goal so I've separately
right I've run my Marathon I've run my
50k I've pulled four plates the go next
is going to be able to be in shape to
know pull four place and run a marathon
not have to be
specialized we'll see if I go heavier
than that but I'd at least like to get
my four plate pull back
deadlift I mean it's not great but it's
not bad either I'm uh 59 180 right
now the deadlift I hit actually pretty
early on into train train i h the
deadlift like nearly 2 years ago now I
think um yeah but then I had to stopped
because of all the running I haven't
done that properly in quite a
why doesn't this have execute
permissions on it
huh love your videos thank
you thank you very much I'm assuming you
saw the latest one
today that one is uh that one took quite
some
work so for the next little bit I'm
going to be sitting here writing some C
and chilling out 305 by5 5 by
195 and 5x 105 I Mayan assume that's
overhead strength
[Music]
training someone got a secret santa the
Ripple toe book yeah I train
so I normally I I train pure strength so
most of my work
is at uh lower reps higher weight
um I don't train for the muscle growth
you know it's I figure that I train for
the strength then it'll look good enough
if I'm strong
right five sets yeah 5 by five so I did
that for I did that for like a year and
a half until it stopped working and now
I have to do a heavy day and a light day
so I'll do like three sets of three
heavy and then maybe on a light day I'll
do like three sets of 6 to eight or
whatever
um current numbers at the moment I've
just been doing the upper body lifts
right so I've got a 260 bench and a 160
overhead at 180 lbs body weight the goal
is to hit 275 bench and body weight
overhead we'll see how long that
takes I got set back a little bit by the
DK that just took uh took the wind out
of my sales a little
bit why the heck doesn't this
work five reps three two one then
five going up in weit each
set 5 3 two
one I don't know that
program
um yeah I don't know that
okay is that the starting strength
one I know that's ripplet to's
book that's probably a safer way of
lifting heavy um if I did that then I
wouldn't be anywhere near my one rep max
by the time I hit the one rep set is the
thing so what I do is I will work up to
a heavy one rep at the start and then I
will back down to my lighter stuff cuz
otherwise I wouldn't be able to hit it
and like the strength development it
really comes from being able to hit the
like 95 plus% of your one rep max
consistently it's been the most helpful
for me
lately all right why the heck isn't this
working can I just
denied
Vim well I'm I can technically just like
I should have
pseudo watch this break everything
yeah I don't know
why something is getting built weird
here oh I'm dumb is why I can't I'm
really stupid is
why incredibly incredibly stupid no no
no I'm just incredibly incredibly
undefined reference
to map offset
is it not linking or something it
doesn't like my inline function
evening working on the mob environment
haha do you notice anything different
about the mob environment here the
code you notice any uh yeah it's
C it's 1500 lines of
C we're going to be able to play this in
the browser soon I'm going to be able to
put a build of it up for you guys to
play with Isn't that
cool and you guys are going to be able
to help me balance it and
stuff is it any faster than scon or you
doing it just for portability nope
sion's native C- speed it's just for
portability it's really not any harder
either like the code is not any harder
than the scon
whatsoever for people who want to
contribute to puffer scon is still 100%
AOK the C is just an option that's like
hey if you want to be able to have this
thing playable online you know we can
make that
happen I figure that 10 times more
people are going to see and play with
the environments um if they're online
right
I try static in line I shouldn't be
needed I can do that but
uh
include all right we'll try the static
though that really shouldn't be needed
whatsoever it's weird oh um by the way
did you see the new the new video I know
you've been looking for the mobile but
that new video is finally out it took
absolutely forever to do but uh oh my
gosh these freaking ads I swear just
watched it
cool how's it doing
134 we're up to
cool it's done I think it's like
relatively okay on
Twitter yeah
96 relatively
okay hey I'm in the first year of
college what books do you recommend to
start understanding Ai and ml o that
depends on your level of General
programming experience um I think that
generally the most the most important
skill set anywhere to have is going to
be yeah a little bit of math but for the
most part being able to just write
competent code
um I honestly think this is a grad
course but it's a very accessible grad
course um
cs231n is the best source for like your
intro to deep learning it's a Stamford
course it's available online get the Le
by Justin or Andre uh carpy either of
those will be good uh don't get the
other lecturers they're not as good um
that's what I would recommend really
more than any of the books is to like do
that course and then actually do the
assignments like I generally think a lot
of assignments are poorly written and
waste and a waste of time but those ones
are like really good as in if you
actually do them and you spend the time
you will understand the fundamentals of
deep learning
and from there you can start branching
out like once you have the fundamentals
of deep learning you can kind of go
anywhere like it would literally take me
probably two months to be up to speed
and productive in any sub area of AI of
my
choice minus maybe a couple theoretical
areas CU I'm more um engineering side
than super math heavy side
thank you I'll take a look yeah that's
what I'd
recommend should deep learning really be
the forc first
goal assuming normal interest starts off
with aggression
classification well yeah but the thing
is like you're going to get that from
your University if you have any sort of
AI related anything like you're going to
have implemented regression a million
times like it's way harder to actually
get the Deep learning section right and
there frankly are not very many good
courses that do it
well like I generally think that like
the vast majority of courses I've ever
taken have been a complete waste of time
so like if I'm recommending a course
it's because it's actually very good
okay that actually
worked I don't know why these have to be
static but apparently they do uh and
this is what we were going for because
now I can actually compile this with the
address
sanitizer percent probability where in
base
reality look the way I look at this if
you'll if you just I'm going to give you
an answer that's a non- answer but it's
also the correct answer if you just look
around at the way that people look at
things in Silicon Valley like you find a
lot of smart people spending a lot of
time thinking about very very stupid
problems and if you look at it from the
outside it's like what the hell are you
doing this is one of them it's a nerd
snipe like the only way to win that
problem is to not think about it
yeah fair and like I'll speculate about
AI thing like AGI things as well
right it's not meant to be taken super
seriously
the mistake I think comes in when like
you get smart people talking about these
problems like not over a beer or like
you know having a a laugh with some
buddies the thing that happens is like
you get these people like you know on
podcast with like a good camera setting
in like a nice armchair you know with a
microphone like with an interviewer and
like talking about these things as if
they're not just wild speculations
that's when you get into real trouble
and then you get quotes like you know
MIT resar says he is going to kill us
all yeah yeah yeah right that's what you
want to
avoid inline by itself does not affect
the linkage of the
function and include the header
file I only include it in one in one C
file so I don't know what's
happening yeah if I if you ever see me
just spouting nonsense in a formal
setting like that please just shoot me
because these people should know
better right like it's one thing for me
to shoot the [ __ ] about like and I can
talk about like yeah I think that we're
going to be able to build Ai and it's
probably going to solve all the problems
cuz like why wouldn't it right it's one
thing for me to be able to do that on
this stream hanging out it's another
thing to have like you know people you
know all dressed up doing this formally
at like non-technical events for people
who don't know any better better than to
like trust the MIT guy
right Nick Bostrom I didn't even I
didn't even have anybody in particular
in mind I just know that this thing
happens a lot cuz every time I basically
every time I see a dumb news article
saying something completely crazy it's
usually from one of these dumb
interviews it's like stop it get some
help H right
here you
see right
here n RNG
r so much
easier so much
easier ah so right here I forgot to do
this because I'm
dumb uh so let's do
this and
1263 and we can just fix all of our
memory issues
is it
[Music]
using I don't know what that
algorithm yeah okay I don't know what
this is It's using whatever the heck RNG
is the default C I don't care about the
RNG quality the only thing I'm doing
here is caching the RNG so I don't have
to sample it repeatedly that's all I'm
doing that is all I am
easy What's Happening Here
What's Happening Here is that there's a
whole bunch of other stuff I have to
allocate isn't
there yeah that's
annoying there's a whole bunch of stuff
I have to
that there's actually a lot of stuff I
have to allocate isn't
there yeah that'll
happen it's okay
though
so we don't need
this um original
copy that's kind of gross isn't it I
just like me
this make GPT do it nope that's how you
get garbage code that's how you end up
spending more time debugging than you
would have spent writing the code while
learning absolutely nothing in the
process I highly recommend super Maven
it gives you like these on Line Auto
completes like this they're very very
fast but you don't don't use AI to just
write your code for you real bad
idea so let's see if this is actually
what we want
here o 11 11
4 and 10 I believe
right * 11
*
4 and
times and let's see if I can get
the OB
size this
is OB size
OBS sides Time 4 and this is
n num
hi I don't know where this player OBS n
is coming
something yeah
26 right
here and their
U
26 too don't hard
code sizes
Malik size of
int um times hold
on six is the number of
actions and then entity star entities is
going to be
equal like
this
okay so now we have all this stuff that
we've just gone and
maled now we go here and we go down
to where is it right
there free original
grid uh then we
and we still have
issues why do we still have issues we
should not still have
issues uh because we allocated the wrong
size of
entity okay so this is saying that we
have for some
reason this is seg faled
really hit
zero okay
well yeah we just we didn't assign it
cuz we're dumb
right good luck out for the evening
going to watch your video awesome time
thank you see you
around
oo buffer
overflows so here you can see that we
actually we got through all the player
allocations right
like spawn
Camp right here this is this needs to be
there and
then where's
this move
to Tower
spawn
Y where did the towers get
assigned I didn't actually see the
towers getting set up anywhere did I oh
no here they
are
pids well I don't know where that got
this idea this needs to
compute observations okay so we get all
the way to compute
uh we have it right here don't
we and forward
death ah but this is the rewards so we
didn't allocate rewards yet I assume
right yeah we didn't allocate
rewards we got to do that next
uh I'm
agents then let's just we'll take
this three
map I thought we allocated both of
these wait we have
right well grid is getting assigned
right
here and then observations map is
getting assigned right
there
[Music]
so
41 wait it tells you doesn't it it says
41 is
Right equals well that's not
helpful
um PID
it'd be nice if I knew which of these it
was so we'll do
in where is it map. Grid it's so it's
unsigned car
Val Ops map and then we'll comment this
so we can see what line it's
on and this tells us
265 okay so it's on the assignment to
the value so we have uh this is
allocated wrong
somehow
really this is allocated wrong
obiz obiz times
4 looks good to
[Music]
uh we get it at compute observations
down
here 1488 that doesn't make any sense we
compile
this 14 86 okay that's
fine
malic num
agents obiz
obiz and obiz is 2 * Vision range +
one
and vision range is five
right okay
let's just double check
that
oops
siiz 11 which is what we'd
expect so we have numb
agents 10 agents
so these sizes are correct I'm assuming
then the cast is somehow
wrong would have to be
right I thought I tested that but maybe
I
didn't so this thing here unsign
Char OBS
H okay so this should give me some
addresses
right YX address so Y is
zero wait OBS
map so PID
zero
y
110 x is
zero and
then address is 1408
80 that make
sense wa Y is
wait
PD okay something is wrong
here
right or is it not
yeah no no something is definitely wrong
here I think I ported this wrong as what
happened this logic doesn't make sense
as
written
because yeah this needs to be like Dy
plus viz or
something so this is a legitimate logic
bug
we'll go find that in a second let's
double
check double checking for comments as
always anything
here oh it's still going a
bit it's that over
100 a decent
let's go
check let's go check the
initial I don't have to do this right
don't I have the initial code I can just
do uh Coba pix don't I have it right
here uh I see what
happened I had to write this custom
because I don't have slices in C that's
what happened
here yeah yeah so do you see this right
here this xx and y y this is what you
want uh and I actually have it here as
well so what
happened this X and
Y with OBS map
I
see I see so I just messed
up so all I have to do is I do
this we're going to have to optimize
this piece of code I wouldn't be
surprised this ends up being slower than
the the scon has
written so this now goes to OB
y yeah so what happened basically is I
was trying to save a little bit of
compute by not doing that check um but
the the structure of the logic had to
change a little bit because I didn't
have slices in uh C the mem slices are a
killer feature for scon by the way if C
had if C had syon memory slices you
could just write everything in C you'd
be very very happy it's so good for
simulations um I'm still pretty happy to
be honest doing this but it would be
even
better okay and where do we
fail yeah we fail in a completely
different place so we got P we got past
this
right yeah we get all the way to respawn
now
X okay let's print the
address come on
weird yeah so you have zeros in the
spawn right
there um and and the reason for this is
that this is no longer a local variable
I refactored that and I forgot to change
it because this doesn't need to exist
anymore uh and now this is way
points eight
whatever I think that that's really
pedantic though isn't
what okay so you can see here that
there's lots of stuff
happening
R
this uh
oops damn
happened
okay six
here player
y
and
ler
y
targets I think that this is going to
fail
right so we get player y player
X Target y
y Target
X index
here Target y Target
because this doesn't have to be
allocated this is static right or am I
dumb wait it's a
pointer but shouldn't that allocate the
pointer array
fix
size yeah
it's fixed sized it gets allocated for
me so what's the
problem 256 by
121 I mean I thought I was like going
nuts but
that's that is how it works
[Music]
so
have
pit well hold on
maybe maybe we have the wrong pit right
did P
scan and now we go to pit zero
right we don't want Target pit stupid
thing doesn't know how to debug
um do I need to allocate this memory
block to be null for
I don't know what the hell it thinks
it's doing here but this is not remotely
correct uh nor do I know why this is 256
but
whatever let's just do this
okay uh I get the
same roughly the same
thing wait wait no it's different
now 321 move
to player
y uh well the destinations are
screwed agent
speed velocity
y okay
more uninitialized garbage to fix
I thought I warned for uninitialized Stu
how did this
happen I thought I got I thought I set
warnings for
but if I see
Alec it's not
guaranteed to be zero either
right CU it's a
float uh that's
obnoxious so I think you do have to just
zero everything right
here and we'll have to do a little bit
of hygiene on this I'm sure to like
reset the struct some something like
that
yeah let's go
right and we're going to go
initially we're going to have to go set
all these things manually to
zero well most of them at
least so PID entity
type hero type that gets set below
doesn't
it let me see because there's stuff
below here that also sets things right
Health damage yeah yeah so this all
these things get
set
um neutrals creep Heroes creeps neutrals
Towers these all Get
Set uh last X and last y get set we're
just going to delete things from here
until we figure out what is uh basic
attack
[Music]
uses we're just going to figure out what
we're not setting
set hero type and grid ID should get set
right hero type grid ID Lane all that
stuff gets
set
um I think it's really just
well you don't set the timers anywhere
either do
you is there like just an easy way to
like set a whole struck to
zero I don't think this this sets the
bites to zero
ah okay
so this is actually safe I'm just being
ridiculous
literally the solution is to just use
cak the alak
whatever and then I don't even need to
do all this garbage
yeah let's just refactor this to
beic I don't know why I wouldn't just
do this in the first place
wrong and anyways I want all this stuff
to be contiguous in memory anyways like
why the heck wouldn't
I okay no more no more malx in the whole
code just
CeX and see like
whatever and okay now we get all the way
to
hear and now this is where we have
actions oops where you can see right
here that we
have and what did we allocate this to
be num agents time
6 it just refactored
wrong look at that it
runs isn't that nice we get to run a
step and [ __ ] doesn't
break that's
awesome
see next the step is going to be to run
a thousand steps
for some reason my auto complete doesn't
work on
c
z
four
that's kind of fast not going to lie
that's 1,024
steps okay you guys want to see
something cool I have not optimized this
remotely now that I've gotten it into
see I'm sure that there's stuff that's
super slow um six how many ticks are we
saying per hour
3600 3600 Time 5 is the tick rate so
18,000 is the
text okay like 4 seconds a little less I
think that was like 3 seconds and keep
in mind I think the init takes a second
as well so Less Than 3 seconds to run an
hour of
DOTA it'll be much faster than that I'm
sure
I think that we said that we could get
it to be like 55 hours or something per
second so it'll be way faster than this
but for an initial first pass I think
that's not
bad as the post the post
so I just realized this means that also
that the minions didn't screw anything
up in an hour worth of games so that's
pretty good to know
right we'll put it like this so we have
faster
tests it is currently
7:13 what do you all think I could
technically technically I could start on
the
renderer that seems like a good
idea we need the renderer in order to do
anything
right we probably need multiple render
modes the initial one is pretty simple
and shouldn't be that hard
we can probably just grab it from the
snake
game and then after that we'll have to
do a little bit more
porting the good thing is
that we're already using
RB and we're already using the Capi for
rib
so it shouldn't be that
hard but we'll
see I'm going use the restroom real
quick and then what we'll do is I
will I'll code on this for like another
20 30 minutes I'll order dinner I'll
continue working on it until dinner gets
here so we'll maybe get like an hour 45
minutes an hour worth of coding in we'll
hopefully at least get we'll try to at
least get the minimal renderer
working that way we can at least see the
game being played in pure C and uh after
that you know tomorrow will try to Port
the whole rest of the renderer and we'll
do other stuff on top of that I mean
it's it's fair enough that this is going
to take like a few days to Port
completely um it's a big
project but still like being able to
Port something of this size in a few
days I'm pretty happy with so I'll be
right back and then we'll do that
all
right I've got a little bit of I've got
a little bit of gas left in the
tank so we're going to actually make
this thing
render if you haven't had the privilege
of playing around with rib yet I highly
recommend it it has bindings for
literally every
language and um it makes doing Graphics
not actually
suck you'll see that in just a second
second
so there are a few things we're going to
have to do here
right I'm realizing that the default
render that I have is a little awkward
because it uses a kind of a weird trick
that doesn't translate very well but I
think we're going to start with
um we're going to start off with
something simil something uh something
simple
I you see we have this entire gigantic
render thing here
ported I really should start off with
some a simple render for this shouldn't
yeah let's just real quick before I do
this
why don't I just grab the renderer from
the snake game and just make it work
with
DOTA because it should be easy like you
see this half a screen of code this is
the renderer for the Snake Game we're
just going to put it here cell size
width height is
fine um
width
height or Mo
MOA Target FPS is going to be set to 10
sure who
cares and I think you need just what's
it called
colors I kind of want to put these here
not at the top of the
colors yeah these are the colors that we
want
and this is almost the
same
right
color
colors
equal then we'll do
autofill does that look correct yes yes
it
does okay cool uh I think all we need to
do now
is ashing
include R.H
right I think it's in a string I don't
think it's installed system wide right
here I thought we did something for
snake to make it easier to build didn't
we
on yeah so we have this compile line
here
this was the solution that we came up
with
so we have this clang
line and we need
to stream is so educational great
service Community thank you is RL Dev
like your full-time job yep um Technic
so I just graduated like a few months
ago this past spring at MIT uh I'm
officially done so as a
result uh I'm now building a company
buff for AI the cool thing about it is
that all the code is free an open source
so I get to kind of just build
everything in the open and uh we just
technically officially launched today I
don't know if did you see the video that
was posted
today if you haven't I highly recommend
it it's like a really really compressed
Whirlwind tour of all the things in
reinforcement learning and how I'm
approaching them with
puffer so heavily recommend that if
you're
new the RL Iceberg
yep just posted that
today that was quite a while in uh in
the
making give it a watch thank
you yeah so um pretty much the deal with
this is I'm just building all this stuff
in the open and uh apparently some
people like to watch Dev so cool and uh
occasionally some people even will come
by and contribute cool stuff so we have
a few different people in the Discord
that are building interesting high
performance
environments you really don't need any
reinforcement learning experience to
build the environments either um and
puffer really automates a lot of the
experiments so you know we have people
building like classic Atari games but
instead of running at the original speed
of those environments they're running at
like a million frames per second or a
million steps per second at least which
lets us do a lot of really fast
research so lots of cool things are
coming to
RL very excited to see where it all
goes Dash shared what is this Das shared
d
o I think I want this line
I need to link I need to include and
Link RB with all the RB Flags
right and then I need to
do this is going to be puffer oh this
isn't going to work because this one has
data
files
right yeah this has data files Okay so
so we will grab this code from here for
now
um we'll grab this from here but we're
going to need to modify a couple
things
MOA come
on man I forgot about that so the issue
is that because we have um data files in
here it'll mess up all the paths if I
like try to put the executable if I
build the executable in the root
directory it'll mess up all the paths to
the data files
oops
right which is really easy to fix but
for now I don't really feel like messing
with it so we're just going to
do like this and we're going to do uh
what's the where are we puffer tank
puffer
lib oops
uh this is
slash puffer tank SL puffer lib
SLR right and we'll just do
slash so we'll just link globally for
what wait what uh but oh SE snake I'm
dumb so yeah this is moaar
oops no member with instruct
MOA n
with no this is renderer withd right
it's a global render now
and then this n grid is actually
n map red
right map
offset and then end
map add we're not supposed to have to do
any math ourselves on the
addresses that was one of the goals of
this
seven what's wrong with this expected ah
yeah I
forgot
what wait color
Colors oh I I messed this up so
color colors and then it ends with a
semicolon
right
color
what' I
do I I'm sure that there's like some
dumb syntax here I'm not seeing right
this is the correct
one
oh do you see
it python style
comments actually can you even do this
at the end of lines like this I think
you can but I don't know
this
uh okay let's fix this one
first let's fix the easy
one initializing int
unsigned yeah let's just do
unsigned Car Star grid equals m map
grid uh map
offset ah we don't need
it yeah so this is now 1533
is it actually that uh you're not
allowed to do comments like this is this
a thing or am I just wasting
time I thought that you could do this
but maybe you're not allowed to do uh
comments in the middle of blocks that
are set off by parentheses like
this maybe the uh the C compiler is not
as
sophisticated I'd be very surprised but
okay no that wasn't
it
that GPT is good for catching brain dead
syntax errors
right look you see
this actual brain
damage didn't have an equal
sign okay perfect um and now what do we
do we have to get the
[Music]
renderer like
Render equal init
renderer uh cell size is is going to
be
2564 width is going to be 128
128 three render
renderer right oops
semicolon it
render and then render n let's see if
this just do
it re renderer is in
invalid implicit
definition
okay open.
renderer
CLS global
lib I mean I know I can just copy it
right
so why would I not just do
that cuz I don't know why else this
wouldn't
Neo may as well be Vim I have a total of
two
plugins but Neo makes it uh
easier to manage like the plugins are
just uh not for Bas
Vim be annoying to set
up but I really like my super Maven
plugin
so like that one plugin is probably a 30
40% productivity boost
right do any
of the legit AI
guys like the
professors I mean I'm no Yen laon but I
hope I'd count like if you want to know
it's like pretty much the ones in their
20s to early 30s do
right so like a lot of the uh the new
phds a lot of PhD candidates and stuff
right there's not really anything else
you can do at the moment for um for
communities right discord's kind of the
best platform to have communities
on so it's really great for organizing
development it's a lot less stiff than
Discord I mean a lot less stiff than
just like doing everything on GitHub
it's a lot more free
form it's really easy to just pull stuff
around
when you were at open AI did you think
they would have so much commercial
success I didn't know commercial as
success but I've been very public in
saying it is the best place I have ever
worked I was an intern there while I was
in undergrad for like six months or so
and yeah was the smartest group of
people I've ever worked with by a mile
um that was really during like the
Heyday of of big Tech reinforcement
learning though right like this was when
DOTA was happening this was like
Starcraft the robotics hand like all
that stuff was happening so yeah it was
awesome now whether they've kept that
same Talent density at their current
scale I don't know right they scaled
really fast and they've gotten way
larger um and a lot of the key people
have left so I have no idea these days
but back then yeah it was awesome and uh
they deserved all the recognition they
were getting then and frankly way more
like I still don't think people
appreciate how crazy of a result open
ai5 was solving DOTA like
I think people just not enough people
had played DOTA like enough people over
40 had played DOTA to like really
understand what a crazy crazy game that
is to
shared oh I
am is this the right
build it'd be good if your
speech and ENT in this
stream uh the platforms not have like I
don't know if x has it but I'm pretty
sure that Mo like YouTube or twitch has
Clos captioning right is that not a
thing it's more of an accessibility
feature right I can't type it into the
chat I I talk way too much for that but
um here if I just go to like my own
are most of the leading people as
passionate no and this is not Arch Linux
I'm on freaking Windows here um I used
arch for like five years I highly
recommend it to people that are like new
to Linux if you want to actually learn
your Tech stack use arch for a few years
that said these days I have this is WSL
I have like a pretty close to Native
Linux environment on it um and all of my
development is containerized so this is
inside of a Docker I have the exact same
Docker on all eight of our
servers um so it's very easy and as for
Vim like I've just been using Vim
forever right I've been using Vim since
I was like 16 that's what I'm used to I
used vs code for like a year I hated it
uh so now I'm back to this let me see if
let me see if the live stream
has uh the Youtube one has
where is
it
subtitles did you get rid of the glasses
to look Max May to look Max maybe a
little but to be fair if I wanted to
looks Max I'd be bodybuilding not
powerlifting so you can't say I'm too
shallow
stream okay so here's the live stream um
oh close captions
unavailable is there not a way to do
this I could have sworn there's like a
live close caption
setting web captioner
okay I will potentially look into
that that's kind of obnoxious that uh I
thought that that already just worked I
thought it was
automatic yeah the running is not doing
anything for my appearance either I will
tell you but it does wonders for the
health
like I had a resting heart rate of I
think it was
like I think my resting heart rate was
like
83 um being very strong before I started
running and now it's down to like 71 72
am I just missing Flags here is that's
what's going
on lib snake.
Soo I don't want this to be compiled as
lib snake. Soo
though I want this to be compiled as
is this right this is this is the
compile
command I
have
oops snake game Snake game.
c g-
o i
isrb l is RB L RB l
yeah I have all the same
Flags so why does this not
agent RL agent used in the game engine
thing for
Doom if you mean the generator like if
you mean the
like uh the model of Doom that's not RL
it's if I recall I think that the thing
you're thinking of was just generative
modeling on Doom to like compress the
game into an engine right I mean
compress the game engine into a
model
um if that's the thing if we're thinking
about the same thing I think that world
models as an auxiliary to RL is a
promising direction of
research
um but I don't think that I don't think
that it's a good idea to substitute the
environment for a model of the
environment I think that that is a
misstep you need the grounding from
having a discret fixed environment uh
and also a lot of the results that are
being shown in these places that as good
are like it would just be better if you
use the actual environment and made it
fast like I actually I mentioned this in
the video that I posted today but uh
Doom actually runs at 100,000 steps per
second uh with puffer that's what we can
get it to
um it's just that there like there's
some obscure configuration settings that
nobody's bothered like looking at but
you can actually get it to run
incredibly
fast we need synthesis yo how's it
going oh you're just in time I actually
I have to order dinner so that I don't
forget to eat but I'm going to keep
deving for a bit while it gets
here the video is out by the way so this
is
here let me go order food on this side
and then we'll keep deving while uh
while it gets here and hopefully I'll be
able to get the thing to render
today oh hey you're going to be really
excited about this so
um put out an iceberg
yeah yeah this is the video this took a
lot of
work I think you'll find it interesting
though like it's made so that even if
you're not in RL like there should be at
least portions of this that that should
be relatively
accessible the idea is that you're going
to learn something if you're brand new
to RL or if you're a world expert either
way you'll learn
stuff so I'll leave this on the screen
while I
order some food on the side
God I also have uh I've got something
you're really going to
like so
I thought it was kind of lame that uh
you're doing all this good artwork and
not that many people are going to be
able to see it because like you have to
download and compile this game
right so
uh I've got 1,600 lines of
c i ported the entire thing to
see and we're going to run this on the
web so literally you're going to be able
to run and play this game online no
download
nothing just in a
browser you're going to be able to play
against reinforcement learned opponents
as
well I was considering doing this to
begin with but then I figured like we
got all this cool artwork now right it's
going to actually look
good so
there you go thank you for uh your
c yeah good choice for engagement and I
literally I prefer to write the whole
thing and C than to touch JavaScript
because screw
gross what's wrong with this
linking now I have to really go ham on
the visual side and I have to get this
to actually render right I got to get to
work but I can say that we're running
the simulation right now and the
simulation doesn't crash uh I have to
get this renderer hopefully I can get
this renderer working for you in the
next 20 minutes or so you'll get to see
at least something just a high level to
make sure it works obviously it's going
to take me another day to Port the full
renderer will take me like another
day yeah I think I thought you'd uh
you'd get a kick out of
yeah so this thing is dumb neither of
these should be needed but we'll do this
for
now
okay
see let's
uh let's check a couple other
things yeah and it's not also it's not
rendering not rendering at scale either
recompile okay so this does actually
scale so clearly nothing is actually
working correctly we have like an agent
jumping around doing weird stuff and
that's
it one on each team it looks
like we can see the creep waves being
spawned and then nothing really
happens so we'll have to fix that but it
does render and this is running in
C and obviously we'll Port the full
renderer
it's
alive yes it is
mark okay well that didn't fix anything
but
uh it's Jumping All Around as well which
is kind of
weird the nice thing is that we do have
debugging capabilities in
here actually better debugging
capabilities than cython even
so spawn
creeps you can see the creeps as well
right that they just don't move
dohon all
right so we now have our debugger
up why can't I
type okay PID is
10 10 correct for a
creep yeah right it should
Fu we got a
creep
what ah the creep pit is negative one
okay so I think we have to set a break
point a little bit higher maybe
1046 mo. AG
PID okay pit is
rebuild and they still don't
move so let's see what that's about
10 pit is
181 that is completely
wrong reap
idx reap index is
creep creep
offset which is numb agents
right
181 all right it's like
this re PID should be 559
mo. H
one hid H is 10 and it's
good 11 that's
good 12 okay so all these things are all
reasonable the only thing I can think
of
Lane less than six less than five would
be 30 total creeps being
spawned creeps 100 there's no way that
creep pit should be negative but should
be 181
um
10 p
and you need PRS 10 so it says that we
have PID 10
here but this thing
local
break H colon 10
one okay so we
have PID
10 and
that I didn't even realize it does that
that's super
nice okay does Cree pit equal negative 1
no it does not update status
creep update cool Downs
creep creep done
timer okay now we get to creep AI
creep
Waypoint
one why is creep wayo
one should be one that's
PID
10 and tick
is okay so we can scan and then
AOE X is equal to Waypoint okay so desk
y
X
move fors
right probably the AI is messed up
towards okay so move towards not
working that's the
now wait we do know that the loading
routine is reasonable
right because we're loading the
grid right and we're loading the
grid the fact that we're loading the
grid and the grid renders correctly this
is the way that we stored it this should
mean that
the uh this should mean that the other
one is
fine AI offset should
be y x d y Source X Source like
correct the pathing being off would
explain
numpy
01 that does not look good
numpy I don't like how this
has n map grid
zero
one
three
four
me oh no cuz I just I just buffer
overflowed
ah wait this is it right here I have the
wrong
moving not
moving move
Char 377 repeats 200 times does not make
any sense
see so this is actually
reasonable because there is a 255
right is there anything else in here
here
though like this should
be I see
it's yeah these are very big
numbers yeah so there there's actually
stuff in here right like you can see
that there's
like there's stuff in
oops okay so this says action is 255 so
let's see what this is
108 uh that's not a valid
destination it's trying to move into a
wall okay so let's see why it came up
with
this back Trace
we're in neutrals it looks
like
and yeah neutrals definitely should not
be doing
this yeah cuz step neutrals goes before
step creeps
right neutral AI
okay so it's on frame one and somehow it
says that it's a scan to
Target
so it says it scan Target with pit zero
which I highly highly doubt
let me see if uh this scan AOE thing is
screwy okay so it
says n
neutral Vision it's excluding
friendly excludes creeps excludes other
neutrals excludes Towers those args look
good I'm assuming the scan function is
screwy then
here
okay
so what we're going to do is
643 and
what are we scanning
here
oops okay it says that we found a
Target this is in Step
neutrals okay it says we found Target
zero so uh I don't believe that so let's
do
player X
y
Target Target y okay so like as you can
see uh first of all those coordinates on
the target are
screwy and second of
all yeah what the heck are those Target
coordinates actually to be
honest ignoring that for the time being
though how do does it think that it
found the target here so it says y x
okay why is
73 x is 43 so this is the
corner
Adder map hit
Adder
ah I
see I found the
error we have to set this to negative
one
okay still not doing
stuff but that hopefully that's one bug
okay I think it's going to be we're
going to run out of time here and I'm
going to have to get food yeah food is
here I'm going to commit this for the
day
though I'll say a couple quick things
before I
creep oh wait are you going to replace
the puffers we need to have the puffers
somewhere in the game
man they got to be
somewhere maybe you can replace the
neutrals or something I don't know like
there's got to be some sort of
puffer there's got to be some sort of
puffer man you're nuts you're trying to
replace I literally have like one good
piece of art total which is this puffer
fish up here and you're trying to
replace this
guy well hey I'm happy to have more uh
more puffer art to
use I'm very fond of the
puffer it's very funny you see
that's a I'd say that's pretty good
progress for the day full sweet that's
awesome well I will look forward to
seeing that I'm going to be I'm going to
be streaming a lot more this week
because like this video is finally done
so um I think we still have a few folks
watching this just a couple so if you
haven't seen it all already check out
this video it's a really thorough
overview of the whole field and all the
stuff in it um let's actually see how
it's doing
for
why do we have just like
absolute garbage ads playing on my
stream get out of
here how do I wait are these
actually oh okay
so yeah take a look at this and
then it's also on here if you
prefer Google comes for its pound it
yeah I swear freaking ads
man
whoa uh so
[Music]
119 we'll see how it does by tomorrow
nice and then we'll see how the video
does on YouTube that's the main
thing watch the iceberg as I doodle It's
a pretty dense video as you'll find it's
pretty
dense but it is it is understandable if
you pay attention to
it anyways I I look forward to seeing
what you come up with in here we have
all sorts of cool stuff
coming wory opponent for density
yeah well we'll see I'll uh I will
gladly await more ah don't listen to
bet uh
yeah I like this guy all
right I am I'm going to go get some food
and I will be uh back streaming by early
afternoon Pacific tomorrow at the latest
so uh thank you folks and I will see you
around